Before this video begins I have an exciting announcement
That... that looked cooler in my head
I designed my own chair!
BAM!
Look at that.
Sexy
sexy... oh
It's so soft in the butt... oh
Now I didn't know about these chairs first, but as soon as I had it I was like oh, man
This is the comfortable...
This is the best thing ever
My ass has been thanking me every single day
It's so goddamn comfortable
And it's so goddamn sexy!
So I worked together with clutch
It's all designed by me
You got the classic PewDiePie sexy lines,
The chair is heavy-duty, steel frame, aluminium base. It's solid. It's solid
the armchairs? four different directions
if you got crazy arms,
I got you fam.
They come with a head re - it comes with a rest
God dammit
This thing?
Double thickness, just like this one.
Oh my gah
And if you got a little extra, as my friend Ethan would say,
FUPA
Then don't worry, this chair's got you.
But I haven't even shown you the best...
*cures his years of backpain*
This is the best thing
Ever - oh, god
This is the greatest invention of all time
It's a little scary at first
But once you get the hang of it
It's hella tight man
So... so the series of this chair usually costs $469.99, if you get the regular one
You get the PewDiePie one, I hook you guys up fam.
$399. God damn it boy
It works well for console gaming, PC gaming...
And it's a limited edition with limited quantity, so don't wait and you won't be disappointed
I'm just so glad I can finally show the damn thing, cuz it's been hidden in my videos for the longest time
I've just been having it down like this just so like you can't see it
Finally - ah! I can sit comfortably
So, if you want yours I highly recommend it.
I've been sitting on such a bad chair for so long and it's been so frustrating
And I've just been refusing to get a proper one and now that I have one
I... I'm so happy with it.
I love the design. I think it's so cool. It looks dope
It really stands out from most of these... type of ones... so yeah
if you want one, link is in the description really appreciate it, and uh
Send me your pics if you get one.
Let the video begin
Slender Man!
You've all heard of him.
What once started
as an innocent Photoshop contest,
turning into a pop culture phenomenon.
Slender Man
Undoubtedly had a huge impact on my channel especially when I was...
Younger [laughs]
I would go on broarmy.net,
or PewDiePie.com, I think it was before,
and I would go to the suggestions page,
where a lot of you guys could suggest me games to play and...
[But] there was one thread.
Legendary thread made by gimme20dollaz
He suggested that I would play the latest Slender Man games.
There was one called "Slenderman"
which I did - I did actually play later.
But he also recommended another one called -
"The second one is simply called Slender; the download link is here."
"The AI is sparse, and the music will keep you in suspense."
[laughs]
I immediately played this game.
I remember, I went online to see if anyone else played it - because back in the day,
YouTube was all about who could play the new popular game first.
It doesn't really... it doesn't really work like that anymore, I would say at least,
But I was like, "Holy shit. This game looks amazing, and no one has played it!"
I made sure to double check, like,
"I'm gonna be the first! This is it!"
"This is my Big. This is my biggety biggety boo."
If you don't know the history of Slenderman,
it basically started as a Photoshop contest on SomethingAwful forums
It then sort of became a meme on the Internet, a lot of fan art was made from it
[Ron Browz - Gimme 20 Dollars]
So I'd heard of Slenderman before, and I knew it was like a big meme
And that's why I knew if the... if there ever was a Slenderman horror game
That would be... really be popular.
So I played it.
in Italy, in that little basement.
Look at me.
[Video] "...horror game."
- "It seems pretty basic."
- "I think it was made for a competition?"
- "Or I'm mixing it up with something else."
[Speaking over video mockingly] "I think it made for a competition."
[Felix] "I am PewDiePie."
[Video] - "I only..."
- " 'Collect all....' Fuck."
- "This does not look bueno..."
- "The sky is nice, though."
- "This reminds me of Haunted Investigation."
[Felix] Good old Haunted Investigation.
[Video] - "This is the first time I ever, um..."
- "seen anything of it, so I really don't..."
[Playable character panting from sprint]
- "...I'm a girl. Good."
- "I have tits."
- "Always wanted to - "
[Felix] Oh my god.
The reaction, quickly, was so terrifying.
[Video] - "Whoa..."
[shrieking in fright]
- "What the hell is that - "
[Felix] Oh my god, it's so cringey dude.
Well...
It spawned a lot of...
other slender videos.
And a lot of other slender games.
So many slender games...
But everyone on YouTube was playing Slender.
Like, all the big channels, people started making gaming channels
You know, Slender was everywhere. It's such a...
...such a huge deal for YouTube.
[stutters] Like, nowadays we have drama,
and, like, vlogs keeping... keeping the trends, but...
back in the day. It was Slender.
[laughs]
I remember screaming so loud, and Marzia's parents were in the home.
I was like "Are they okay?"
"I'm sorry I yelled so loud."
But I thought, you know... we have to play the game
We gotta check it out.
The orig - the OG copy. How scary could it be?
- "Whoa."
[shriek of fright]
Parsec productions is -
Which also made Slender... another slender version later,
which was kind of disappointing, I guess.
'Collect all eight pages.' That's all you know
Look at this - stock Unity
ah... forest, you know?
This is like...
...as simple as it gets, man.
But the lack of visibility,
the fact that the flashlight goes down when you run,
I don't know, it makes it scary.
I think something about the woods really scare me as well
Especially grow - growing up by the woods in Sweden.
I really... oh it always freaked me out not knowing what was out.
It's so easy to hide, you know, behind the trees and shiz
Alright, I know I'm fine until like...
Until I get a couple pages.
My god, oh... I'm a girl! I have tits.
Oh yeah, and there was this building...!
I was like, "What is in this building? I'm so scared!"
It's just like a skeleton of a building
Like what is this?
Oh, my god, you really do run out of stamina fast.
I don't know if I ever beat the game to be honest.
It was really hard
to get all eight, like...
I remember trying super hard
But then again, I wasn't such a Pro Gamer back then.
I can't even find one page, dude!
There it is.
Nice. Dude, I'm getting goosebumps.
I'm not joking, this game gives me goose bumps still.
It just did tension so well, the building of tension
Like, "Oh shit. I'm doing something wrong.
I'm not supposed to do this."
Oh, my god, it's still scare- I'm still like getting spooked out. This is ridiculous.
Grow the f - up, Felix, okay?
It's just a stupid Slender Man. I'm not scared of Slender Man!
I remember, there's a spawn here... but god damn, she's slow
We have yet to meet our friend though...
our compadre...
Oh - oh - something's happening!
Let's not go that way!
I guess no...
spawn...?
Man... I get itchy when I'm sweating man, I don't like it.
This game is making me nervous!
Is he over there? He must be over there.
Oh, there he is - Oh my god. I am so scared of you.
You are so spooky
you so spooky, mister man
Okay, okay, all right, we got it.
What up mister Slendy. He lookin sexy as always
I really - he's really just teleporting around too, like there's no character animation
It really shows how...
...just in games, like, in movies
Simplicity in horror works so much better.
Well, I forgot how shit this game was.
[laughs]
Ahhh
It's so uneventful dude...
2017 PewDiePie would have just quit by now!
Did I check this one?
There it is.
Oh, wow, it gets super-scary now that I have three.
God damn, I gotta get four more? I mean, five more?
Math... is related to science?
Ha!
Oh, look he's up our ass now boy.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, there - there's a paper there. Let's go for it.
Four, motherfucker! Whoa!
We're doing good man. Hell yeah.
I'm gonna get all - Oh!
I'm gonna get all of them, Slender...
Oh!
The good old [jumpscare noise imitation]
Goddamn, I'm so itchy! I'm like, ahhh!
Stop making me sweat, Slender Man. I don't like it
I'm not in bed ready for you, baby
Show me those tentacles....
The sex jokes have not stopped apparently. Great.
Oh. Well, I guess we're not going that way.
Okay, I guess we're not going that way either.
Oh my god. We're just walking in circles, dude.
[yells in Swedish fright]
What the hell dude? I'm not scared, shut up!
Oh...
Pathetic, man.
Pathetic.
What do I even need the pages for, huh? What am I gonna do with them?
How is that gonna stop him? How about I just go home?
What the heck...?
I didn't even do anything!
Oh, shoot... oh, shoot
[The] game is just farting in my face now... like what the...?
oh, he's right there.
Dude, It's so dark. Like, I can't - is this is even on?
Where am I?
Oh! Snappity boopy.
Whoa, what is this?
I found something!
Is that another note? Yes!
Come on! Number five!
PRAH
PRAH PRAH PRAH...
And that's the way the news goes!
Wubba-lubba-dubba....
I can't - I can't see anything, dude.
I'm blind
Did my flashlight run out?
Oh snap-a-snoop-a - !
Oh my god!
Well I guess I ran out of time because I was too slow,
but hey, five pages. Not bad, eh? Not bad, eh?
What have we got, the extras?
I could play without a flashlight. I can play with a dildo, is that it?
Wow. So that was Slender: The Eight Pages.
It's funny how...
five years later.... It still makes me sweat, man
[laughs] Jesus....
Oh... my god.
I feel like I sort of moved away from the horror stuff
Mainly cuz I'm kinda bored with it.
It's been... I played every game. I played every single indie horror game ever
I don't know. It just doesn't have the same impact on me
I mean, I'd be a fool if it still did.
That doesn't mean I [don't] still enjoy it
And I'd really look back at slender as...
some fond memories of the channel.
That being said, there are some horror games coming out that I'm looking forward to play on this channel
Evil Within looks fun.
I think we... ah... will do a playthrough of that, and then maybe that will be something interesting or not
I don't know. That's the point of horror: you never know if it's going to be good!
Thank you guys so much for watching,
leave a like if you enjoyed,
and Squad fam out
[T errified Swedish shrieking]